s'agisse vraiment de valoriser la
production locale mais aussi de
faciliter l'écoulement de cette
production sera partenaire les
producteurs nous faisons des animations
cette foire semaine thématique ou autre
et ça nous permet cela permet aux
consommateurs d'avoir des produits à bas
prix pas trop cher
ça veut dire de vivre convenablement
donc tout le monde r oui absolument
c'est un contrat passé avec ce que je
pense je dois lui a vu l'euro repasser
la sécheresse en voyage je savais saison
2 et national de faire des tonnes de de
pastel dauphine de melon
on s'est lancé dans les falaises de
légumes voilà donc on est beaucoup
dynamique que cela permet en même temps
d'animer le centre-ville et de valoriser
l'action marchand la preuve de cet
intérieur voulait vraiment apprécié les
marges de saison besoin de cette
animation est ce que chaque col de
comprendre où c kon de christopher ça se
termine aussi rapidement
oui ça se termine rapidement ça n'est
pas des période mais il ya des
périodes où secteur dès que j'ai vu ne
faut pas deux heures donc là on est à
l'avant veille de la fête des mères
donc je pense que ça ira parce que j'ai
de très bons prix et les produits saubot
la chose que nous avons c'est comme ça
que tout a évolué coeur donc je vois des
produits qui passent à chaque fois tu as
pris le bateau données produits qui
sortent du champ de la veille pour l'onu